fumiko la japonaise quelle île
australienne au col africains ou
geronimo le chilien prolonge donc leurs
vacances de noël pendant deux semaines
ils partent vivre la grande aventure de
l'antarctique une leçon de géographie et
d'écologie grandeur nature seoul
antarctique solide et c'est bien lannoy
d'abord d'avoir un peu froid il en
danger de quoi l'antarctique en ce
moment déjà il ya les trous dans la
couche d'ozone est l'arrêt peut fondre
et rien et un danger de pollution
à cela s'ajoute la menace d'une
exploitation minière
alors après les réunions les conférences
les discussions le commandant cousteau a
choisi les enfants qui construiront une
maison de glace symbole de la prise de
possession du continent blanc par les
jeunes générations
il faut le préserver c'est un autre le
protéger si les enfants de les protéger
enfin aux enfants et aux chantiers qui
seront après nous tu crois que des
enfants le pouvoir de protéger
l'antarctique
mais quand ils seront grands ne touchez
pas l'emporter c'est pas notre affaire
c'est la sphère des générations futures
voilà ce que ça veut dire notre mission
cousteau et son équipe ont déjà
recueilli plus d'un million de
signatures pour que le continent
antarctique soient déclarées et
reconnues réserves naturelles
internationales